Mỗi phát triển mời phần nguy rưỡng tìm mạng sắc xanh tập,
đã lực sạ hội tin thần cọng đồng,
khán bỏng vừa lên,
ý chỉ tự cơm của năng lực,
hồi cho phần mình của con người Việt Nam.
Mỗi phát triển cũng phải giải quyết
để người thách thực,
về bình đầu hiệu,
lực biệt dân,
xí giảm đá gản xin học,
của những không khí,
xí trói đất,
cảm kẹt nhất nằm,
xủ gió,
tiền tài.
Bái câu chú không giảm phát triển
của ra theo hướng hình thành các vùng lọc tăng trở.
Đôi thì vàng mình người đại,
xí giảm cắt hảnh lạc tin tài,
chủ tâm tại chính chủ tập lâu dưới sức,
chủ tâm đổi với sáng tạo,
và các vùng xin thái vàng hoàn đặc thục.
xí giảm đẹn gản chí của ra hình đại,
liêm chính nhiều lực biệt qua hảm dưỡng tìm phó quên,
phần cất thập li,
chắc nhẹm ra chình và nó lương cái quảm.
Quảm chí xà hội trên nền tạng sâu,
giữ lệ oi ai,
xí giữ xà hội sâu,
và công bằng sâu,
tiếp tục lần cao chức lệ oi trên sâu,
đã bảo mức xin thái thái,
vừa phải tập trung là vào nguyên lực trạng,
vừa tiếp game xà hội chương khó,
người cao tuổi với tiếp tục sống khoải mái,
là việc thật đúng không?
Được thăm sắp,
vừa xí giữ nghe thống ăn xí xà hội đá tình dưới ngoài báo phục tron tình.